now women earn less than men in every
Advanced economy in the world this is
despite a slew of policies aiming to
redress the balance on years of
discussion about the topic according to
the United Nations for every dollar a
man earns a woman takes home just 77
cents
a court efforts to address the issue are
well underway but at the current rate of
progress it would take
257 years to close the gender pay Gap a
recent study by the journal Nature human
behavior has taken a closer look at the
issue researchers looked at the
situation in several advanced economies
you can see a sample of them here and
the difference in Pay between men and
women in each one now the study came to
some interesting conclusions which my
colleague Arthur Sullivan has been
looking into that's got the breakdown
from him now
hi guys thanks for coming on
I'm wondering this study seemed to
really upend some of the assumptions we
have about the causes of the gender pay
Gap why is that yeah so one of the big
underlying assumptions which has been
behind a lot of the research that's been
on the gender pay gap for decades now is
that the majority of the issuer and the
peer Gap comes from things called
sorting and segregation issues in terms
of jobs so that basically means that
women end up in lower paid sectors now
obviously there are structural
um descriptive structural discrimination
within that in that a lot of those
sectors which become in quote marks
feminized are structurally undervalued
but what's fundamentally different about
this study is it shows that to a much
larger extent than previously thought
what's known as within job inequality is
actually responsible for half the pay
Gap that means men and women doing
essentially the same work or been paid
less so it's not because women are doing
different jobs that are typically paid
less it's because they're actually
simply paid less even though they are in
the same job and that accounts according
to this study for roughly half of the
pay Gap in the 15 countries that are
profiled okay so if we know that this is
happening the obvious question is what
can we do about that well one of the
things that the authors of the study say
that's so important for this study is
that there's different sets of policies
required so in cases where it's
um the segregation issue it's important
to encourage women to come into jobs
which are better paid but this other
issue this within job inequality is is
more difficult to deal with but there is
one consistent policy thread that's
required and that's pay and wage
transparency and there is some work been
done on that for example the EU has
brought in a directive which should come
into effect in the across the EU over
the next two to three years which would
dramatically change the rules on wage
impaired transparency would give
employees the right to get quite
specific details on pair structures
within their organizations also would
prevent employers from asking them about
their own salary expectations things
like that and would also give workers
the right to pursue claims if they feel
they've been unfairly discriminated and
that's one of the key areas that needs
to be addressed Germany has brought in
its own law and disregard a few years
ago there's a lot of criticism of that
law for example one of the big ones is
that you must be have at least 500
employees for a lot of its requirements
to come into effect so hopefully for for
those seeking a closing of this pay Gap
this EU directive will be a big big
changing point I want to talk a little
bit more about Germany specifically
because it has one of the highest gender
pay gaps in the EU and that's despite
some pretty Progressive policies you
mentioned ever to change there but
looking specifically at parental leave
we have this very generous policy where
mothers and fathers can divide their
time equally but that doesn't seem to
happen why is there a motherhood penalty
here and no fatherhood penalty yeah it's
one of the really interesting things
about this study and the authors
themselves have said that Germany is a
bit of a puzzle to them because Germany
does indeed have those Progressive
policies policies one of the best
paternity benefit systems in the world
and yet there is this consistent
motherhood penalty in Germany and also
the a pay gap which does lag behind a
lot of the equivalent sort of peers in
northern Europe especially now it's hard
to say exactly why that is but one of
the things is that women because of
pre-existing inequalities tend to be in
the Lesser paid roles and so it's a
self-reinforcing issue that women will
tend then to take a little bit more
leave obviously has more there's also
because of the fact of pregnancy they
will tend to take a little bit longer
there may be health issues during
pregnancy and things like that and they
may miss out on opportunities during
that period it also tends to occur that
German women often will get pregnant in
their 30s and that's obviously a
critical time in career development so
there are these issues that need to be
addressed and again policies have to
come in to further level the playing
field for women to take into account
these issues another issue very briefly
within Germany is that it's a lot of its
economic Edge comes in industrial
sectors and there still is not of
recommend representational women in
those areas okay Arthur Sullivan thank
you so much